Pakistan's prime minister Imran Khan has
been ousted after losing a vote of no
competence earlier Mr Khan said that he
will not accept an opposition government
and warned that the U.S was leading a
conspiracy to remove him the acting
Speaker of the House announced the
results of the vote just a few hours ago
174 members have recorded their votes in
favor of the resolution
consequently the resolution for vote of
no confidence against Mr Imran Khan the
prime minister of Islamic Republic of
Pakistan has been passed by a majority
of the total membership of the National
Assembly
[Applause]
thanks guys summer motion joins us now
she's in Lahore so Simon it's been back
and forth for a week now but they have
voted him out tonight
they did and it was at the turn of
midnight Imran Khan really pushed uh the
Judiciary the Parliament and even the
military in the last half hour just
before that boat took place Sky News was
told that both the chief of Army staff
and the is it had visited him we have
seen a helicopter hovering over PM
Health we were then told that they were
inside now that vote took place and the
opposition was jubilant let's hear what
they had to say
I congratulate Pakistan in this house on
its first successful no confidence vote
and we've made history
that is of course Benazir Putin
he and other members of the opposition
created a coalition to oust Imran Khan
not the dignified exit this icon of
Pakistan was wanting of course this is a
man who is a cricketer who brought the
World Cup to Pakistan and he wanted to
be the the savior of Pakistan if you
like as the Prime Minister who brought
Justice to this country fighting a
corrupt opposition in the end he gave
way to that opposition we understand he
has left PM house tonight Imran Khan is
out for now